hey guys also going so I am feeling
pretty terrible I've been sick for the
past few days and I didn't have a video
for today so I thought what could I do
that might make me feel better and I can
still post video for you guys and have a
nice bit of chat so I thought I'll play
some Super Mario Brothers this is the
Super NES a little classic edition it's
a little tiny console - basically looks
like a mini idea so we're going to play
and I'm going to see what happens and
this game with any time I play it if you
need much flashback to my childhood
because you couldn't ever save your
games
so you basically had to just kind of
like leave your console on and your
parents were like hey you can't do that
then they would turn it off and you lose
all your progress
it was really really sad time so you
just don't know how good you have it I
don't mean to sound like super elderly
but man in it thanks this was high tech
is it God you know I just don't know if
you guys have a full concept of that if
you are a small child and if you aren't
a small child and you understand and you
Arsenal child man let me tell you it
gets better
and can't-can't hopefully yeah let's
just keep away Oh guys I escaped makes
me so happy and plane is on a small
little monitor so it's the actual screen
size on my monitor it's like big big so
I can barely even see it
[Music]
there's a kind of warp zone hoping that
I can remember where they all are so
that I can basically just cheat my way
to victory I remember the first time
that I ever found one of the warp zones
it was kind of I don't know it was like
it was like a whole new world opened up
in my eyes it was with what I can jump
all the way level for world for absolute
dream come true well what was your
favorite old-school game and if you've
never played any of these games before
what current game is your favorite now I
hate the spiny funnies why do I bother
datapoint
mean and of course I would like to get a
1-up but oh man I've been playing so
much Super Mario run it's so weird to
play this and not be constantly running
because a lot of people would did
complain that Mario run they didn't like
how you constantly ran I loved it I
thought it was great I could lay down a
bed and play this game and not even have
to think twice not anything I just hit
the screen on my iPhone and Mario jumps
and continues on okay so this is where
thanks Mike hello a little silly just
see if I can do this
because you can be small so that I'm
able to get in there I don't think I can
sounds like you can jump and be a little
I try still be silly thing get
it I get it I get it there a little work
okay well shoot but kill myself or what
do I do I'm just going to kill myself so
that I can get the cheat my god work my
body not going to make the same mistake
I'm just going to roll up to the scene
with my feeling missing hit that off get
it got to get it it sucks that I could
have had my my big Mario but I could
never do it properly nickel is cool
that's good coin op does anybody else
have the little NES console I can't
believe it they're still so hard to find
like it's crazy like I just can't
believe that they didn't make more
they're so cool and the switch is coming
out very soon
edits can be such a fun couple of months
for gaming I suppose there were more
games out for switch I feel like they're
launch titles are too strong but the
rest of the year especially can going
into holiday with Mario Odyssey and yeah
emigrate and Mario Kart comes out in
April
super pumped for that oh yeah baby
net star
[Music]
I looked over to make sure that I was
still recording and then I lost my I
lost my game you got a do without a - we
got a do not focus gotta stay focused
and stay alive like old school call
duties to teach other in this playing
college do you know if the next one will
be fun
I didn't play in warfare at all I played
a bunch of the modern warfare remastered
and then I'm gonna play I'm not enjoying
this
so I'll waste my time walking up which
instead oh my god I was on that was good
hold level very very very very very very
much
[Music]
oh my gosh that was super scary I was
not prepared for that so the best part
about the little patti-anne yes if you
can save where you left off you can
spend points so I don't feel like
playing this all the way back from the
beginning so I'm basically just gonna
cheat my way to victory at this point so
if I die I can go back to wherever I
left off so I don't care
shun me le1 mommy's beating this game
today that one up will help me oh I'll
take it yep hold on I'm sitting this is
something you could never do but I feel
like this is 100% cheating but I don't
care I was the satisfaction of getting
this victory
oh my god
watch watch what I can do cheat I
wouldn't call it cheating per se but
it's definitely not how the game needs
to be played makes it like now games if
you have putting set expectation of how
things are I don't know I don't think I
don't know it's just everything is
different
am I having fun yeah I'm having fun I
don't care if I'm technically not
playing and how are used to play it
sorry no no please don't kill me oh my
god that was really a really great move
in a very problem no either way I mean I
freaking love this game so I'll play it
how I want to play it I'll so much more
accomplished even if I use phase points
if I get seated oh gosh oh god watch
cioppino very soon that was super super
sketchy that was coolest man super close
well a three-member the first time that
I saw this brick wall I had the feeling
that it was almost time it was a whole
time that I was going to beat this game
and I was gonna be so excited and
everything was going to be great and the
victory would be mine I think no time
ever son I'd ever really had that
feeling because I think it's like a
first game that I never played so
clearly you know never knowing what it's
like to beat a game
[Music]
get him get him
oh god how the heck did I jump over that
guy I have absolutely no idea oh my gosh
I'm so scared right now I got faith we
got saved man we're beating this we're
beating this game am i Friday oh god I'm
so terrified
[Music]
I can't even speak up TM saying okay
let's go
it's okay all right I'm going to nervous
[Music]
can't wait
ah it's so crazy because I don't have
that same feeling of I was fine it's
totally fine it's really actually matter
because I can just restart and start
back from where I was before but if you
died previously I mean you would start
all the way back from the beginning from
the very very beginning every weakness
[Music]
they're like flapping down one of these
I don't remember I just feel like I kept
doing this forever in an Oreo
I don't actually remember that by the
dance
no this is not good definitely open on
that one so let's maybe traffic over
Tomlinson take it on this once I go down
good on that one
it's it's it's 216 I don't remember
[Music]
they didn't go down I don't remember
cute I hate everything
[Music]
yeah I don't go down anymore Oh body
this is where we came from for please oh
boy everything is not awesome oh my god
I forgot about those pigs holy crap holy
crap do I just keep running I think
that's not a number
oh my god no I definitely have to go
down something okay oh god what what is
this oh boy okay we have to say we have
to save this is pathetic this is
pathetic and I don't care hey teasing I
don't want to hear it I don't want to
hear it
I'd like for you to be nice to me please
No shut up egg
[Music]
please let me win the game they were
saving again we're saving again I'm
pathetic
don't care absolutely don't care who
cares nope not me at all
holy crap
hey did it no oh thank you Mario it's
been dusted another two for corporate
over we present you with a new quest
recipe and Celestin world oh body only
goodness saving we're saving saving
hello yep pig oh gosh
get away from me get away well at least
I feel like my childhood has definitely
been relived I'm happy and super
stressed out I feel awful and I think
that I probably made myself more sick by
the hooting and hollering that I just
did I'm definitely playing this maybe I
am I don't know what's happening
I just know that I'm in a very stressful
day right now
yeah Delon I don't think I really wanna
play this again do I yes I do oh my god
yeah I do
no I don't I don't want you I don't
wanna yes I do
I'm having some I'm fighting with myself
boxes happening right now
[Music]
I'm not going to do this right now but I
am going to save it and perhaps I will
come back here at a later date maybe
look in my next video maybe I'll do this
again if you guys enjoyed it if you
didn't well hey that's the best thing
about YouTube if you didn't like it and
you tell me it in like it I'll never do
it again
or mean hello Oh No thank you guys for
watching I'm stressed I need to video
gather my thoughts and that is this
video so see you later bye here we're
about to keep your pretty slowly
rehearsal is happening
we are going to shoot over the web
segment for dr. Ava's YouTube channel
yeah it really has a YouTube channel
I'll do it in the description to his
channel hands